so this was the subject of your recent
podcast outlets that's right so we
decided to take a break from certain
other commodities market which has been
dominating the headlines recently and
look at another one specifically the
market for bananas which is really
interesting at the moment because as it
turns out it's under threat from this
disease called Panama disease what's
even more interesting is that it was
once under threat from the very very
same disease the problem with bananas if
you listen to the podcast is that we
have a single breed that dominates
something like 95% of the world's crops
so what I found really fascinating when
we had this discussion is we have why we
have dozens and dozens of different
apples but we only have one banana and
yeah furthermore it's very boring plain
banana and they write unfortunately we
could all be eating far more interesting
bananas but we're eating this one
specific type of banana called a
Cavendish and the reason it's happened
is because of the way the banana
industry kind of grew up so you think
about the big banana companies of the
1800s Early 1900s they developed this
infrastructure that worked to deliver a
really really cheap banana to people
like you and me in the States but at a
cost and the cost is it relies on one
single breed that's basically easy to
ship and transport so when I get
different labels for different bananas
and like different companies and
organics is not it's all the same one
95% certainty it's a Cavendish banana so
what happens if this disease kind of
takes over I mean is there any kind of
cure I mean literally well people are
talking about genetic modification
there's some other sort of solutions in
the works but it's a really really big
deal because again 95% of the world's
banana crops are this one type of banana
and a lot of people rely on bananas not
just further livelihood but also for
their food sources so another source of
food scarcity and it's not like we could
grow our bananas in different countries
in different climates and be rid of this
disease know this Panama disease is
really really bad at spreading it gets
attached to people shoes you know a
single piece of soil can kind of ruin a
whole country's banana crop does it do
it's a sort of like I think it's like a
root rot it's called facili 'm wilts
it basically another figures Alex on
their technical question thank you
drives away this disease you asked me to
do banal upon one thing that was
interesting is you know you talked about
this infrastructure that's been designed
for this one banana and it's intuitive
when you think how easily bananas
bruised how you can't refrigerate them
and so forth think about it you go into
the supermarket and you're getting a
tropical fruit that's coming from far
away and it's the cheapest one in the
market it's cheaper than apples of you
know grown in Washington DC there's not
Washington DC Washington State there's a
reason for that and the reason is this
big infrastructure built around a single
banana but the price of that single
banana the cheap single boring banana is
fragility and adeno the danger of this
Panama disease